Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's VR.
OH BOOO!
It's a Bonnie and he's closer. You're very clearly closer, but I'm not gonna worry too much about you
So next up on the list of things that I need to do is I need to do parts and service for Bonnie
Which means I gotta touch, Bonnie, all over and I you know..
I gotta fix Bonnie, I don't know why Bonnie's broken and I don't know why this is my job to do this
But apparently it's my job to do...
What the fuck....
what the-
What the fuck
wait, wait was that always like that?! I don't know about that one, okay. "repair Bonnie grab and release, pull trigger"
Pull trigger. Push buttons, make repairs.
Oh!
Just that easy, huh? Okay. Alright sure, whatever
Alright, OH FUCK
God, why?
God fuck you!
Oh..
Ohh..
OH!
OHH!
OHHH!!
Awh-wh
Are you fucking kidding me?! Look at this shit! Oh my god! Oh my god! Oh my god!
Oh my god, you are fucking huge. I don't know if this is coming across in the video. But oh my God, LOOK AT YOUR LEEEG!!!
WHAT ARE THOSE!? *smh* Oh my god, your fucking kneecap
It's bigger than my hand your hand! Okay, maybe we're not that too far off. Okay, maybe you're big! You're big!
Definitely big you you big boy Oh
boy? Question mark all right left eye.
*confused stuttering*
Okay alright, let me look for a sec- Hey look a coin!
Yaaay!
Wooo, hey a bunny!
wooo another coin!
Eyyyy!
uh oh.
Hey you're not gonna be mad about that are ya?
You're not gonna be mad-
Hey, hey, Bonnie. What the fuck you gonna do when I punch your little Bonnie buddy in the nose, you know
Baby bon: NO SAVEMEPLEASE! Mark: No, I you can't save me you're so stupid through boink boink boink
Baby bon: OH HE'S BEATING ME UP!!! Mark: boink x3! ha! loser. DOINK. Yeah, get some of this!
UH DOINK! this is what I think of this guy I
Thought that was gonna be like a meat grinder or something...
That didn't work out nearly as nicely as I thought UHDOINK x3
Who's a dummy now?! DOINK DOINK whatever you stay right there
Whatever, it's good enough. Okay, now that I've properly psyched myself up to be scared by you
If you even fuckin move for a second outside swear
I'm gonna I'm gonna sock you right in your noise. Who's gonna get some of this A DOINK
Yeah, you can tweak up now rip your teeth out one by one foot the weak. Alright, here we go. Oh
*mark getting scared*
*regretful mark sigh* (spent too much time hyping up)
Follow instru- I DID?!
I DID. I DID. Oh my god.
It's like a game of operation isn't it?? Okay Bonnie, I'm gonna try this again
You're gonna be nice. You're not gonna be a douche. We're gonna get through this
just be
AH!
Ah,  fu-
Why?!
Oh, his left eye!
Oh, ow!
His left eye! Not my left! His left!
*anger mark noises*
His left! Not my left! His....your left!!
Give me that...
FUCKING EYE
My left!
Okay, boink.
Yeah
Gonna get this shit
I'm not an idiot. (scroll through your make videos..)
*joyuos mark noises*
I AIN'T NO DUMB. I AIN'T NO DUMB.
Did you..? Did you move?
You're not moving are ya? You wouldn't be moving would ya? EH? EH?? Alright, here we go
OH FUCK!!
I swear to god.....
you are
Even worse on the inside! And I didn't know how that would be possible, but my god, look at that! It sure is.
Okay, here we go
Oh
Yeaaah..?
Oh, just that easy! It's a musical interlude I know which it was...
*sarcastic mark* Great..
Wait.....in the same order?
I removed them...meaning not the reverse order! So I gotta go, his left then right?
That's his left. That's his right? You can't fool me. I'm not an idiot
Okay, I'm not dumb I'm not
You've never looked prettier. (marnnie) Oh my goodness. Look at you. You are just the spitting image of a nightmare. Oh,
Yes
See YOU next time Bonnie!
See you next time. Hey, we're doing pretty good guys!
Guys can you believe it?!
WOOOOWWW!! A WHOLE CAKE!! (no it's a piece.)
Ooh I don't know if I should.... What does this spell out?  Who's birthday is i- NOM!
Not as tasty as the...the pumpkin muppet.. (wha?)
Marionette. Not as tasty, but pretty good! Pretty good!
All right, great hey chica is up next! And that's cool! So I'm looking forward to this
Grab release push buttons make repairs easy
*confused cursing mark*
OH MY God!!! (they killed kenny!)
This is a normal can of soda
It's empty, cool. Hey, hey
Okay, all right bones
That's no the box give me the box
Oh
Pug, I love bugs bugs are good arm
whoa
Oh
It's like an old soda bottle. Hey, how you doing, buddy?
Nothing under you, right? You know, you don't mind if I eat
Do you?
Excuse me, Oh, oh, I can't eat it. Why not?
Hey, oh, oh my god
You're you're adorable
You're a toy chica plushie. See that's your big sister. She's a little ugly, but we're gonna make her pretty.
HADOINKUS HADOINKUS HADOINK-
(you're gonna regret that -_-)
fix that beak right up
tHat'S nOt SupPoSed tO bE ThErE
HABOOF!!
(noooo mark that poor thing)
EUUUGHHH
(you are really gonna regret that)
Plushie Chica: Ohh, help me big sis...
Mark: No.
AAHHH, OH FUCKING GOD
FFFUUUCK
HEH HEH
HEH HEH HEH
*echoing...
All right, I guess I deserved that one.
All right remove all the food particles. I get that. I respect that. hey that's-
Oh hello, all right
yaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaay
One of those whatever that means it take that. Excuse you and just one of these
ooKiE?
Okay, not for me then
wha?
Okay
Easy as that
Don't you do nothing?
*click
YAAAAAAAAAAOOOOWW
*disgust
OHHHH
ohhhhhhh
Yeah
okay, yeah
That's, yeah
Okay
Oh- okay
ooowww
holy god
(be careful mark!)
AHHHHH I- FUCKING I'D-
There was bugs out! i was trying to change hands, it didn't work!  Goddamnit, fuck you. Alright you piece of shit
Alright, that's how it's gonna be. You know, first you first you- da ah whatever
Yep, fuck
ada d- DOiNkus
uh
UUAAAAAAAYYYY
You don't even try that
yea yea yea yea
WHOO
yea yea yea yea yea and...
there we go!
looks like-
WHOOOAAAA
OHKAY
HUH HEE HUH
okay?
WHOA HEY WHOA. WHOA
WAI-
wha-
wha- wai-
get-
GET OVER HERE
WHADAYOUDOIN
wha-
whaeuguughghhh
uh...
uh- OHHH
yaaaaaaaaaaaay
See you next time! hahahahahahahahaha
(sarcastically)
hahahaha
This is the weirdest fucking-
WHOOOOAAAAEEEEEYYY
OHHHHHHHHH
BOOOOYYYY
Real live robot BEEP BOOP. I have a soul.
I'm lost
the child who was stuffed into an apple poo
ohh you suck
aright go away
OHH WHHAAT DA FAAACK?
uh..
okay..
Hi?
um..
Can I help you? You've- OOF. Got the microphone. You're trying to point out this button? cuz I know about that button
I don't know what the button does
but uh push the buttons
dudududushhhh
There y-
Yes, so there is that. I don't know what that means, but I got a new tape
SO AMA FIND OUT HAHAH what this is about
here we gooo!!
That was it? Okay great. Thanks for the story. I still know why the little helper Bear is here
Oh, no, never mind. Helper bear not there anymore. We don't need that helper bear there doing
nah ah ah nah ah
Goddamn nah, not even a little bit. Okay. I don't know what that button does
I have a funny feeling it makes this harder so-
BOOINKUUSS
aaaaand-
doink! (misses)
nope
aaaaaaaaand doink!
okkeeehh
Grab and release. Push buttons. Make repairs
BOIINK
Alright. Come on FFFfreeddy
Y- you'd think you'd mess with meehhh?
OOOOHHHHH HOH HOH HOH
(merry christmas!)
OHHHH
wha-
uhm (confused markimoo)
Why is their child's hat-
in your mouth?!
you're SO BIG (really mark?)
I'm at crotch level
Why?
Why am I at your crotch level?
No!
I-
I have many problems with everything that's happening here, right and now. Anything in there?
I want a coin for this. Give me a coin.
Or amana (I'm gonna) FREAK
Oh whatever
Down here? whoo I dunnooo
(NOOOO DON'T DROP THAT)
FUCKING GOD
FUCK
-ING
I
AM TRYYYINGG
To be a good boys
GIMME DA HAAT
Okay
(that's a fucking trash can right there tho)
Okey-dokey
ohh no...
AHH BOOHHH
BEEUGHHGHHHGH
AHAHA (what's so funny tho?)
EHEHEH
EHHHHHHHHHHHHH
EUUGHHH
Fuck.
ohhhh
Ohhh
OOOHHHH
WAAHTT-
EH-
DUUAAAAAHHHHHHHHH
Awright
Ohkaaay
EHH HEEEHHH
Hey guys, I got it. Paaarty tiiime!
Okay
Right right, right
What? What? Wait what?
What safety?  Wait safety latch? What are you talking about? What are you talking about? A safety latch what? sa-
Is that the music box? Am I? Are these music boxes? Is that?
Don't
(oh no)
FUCK OH GOD FUCK
??????????
HEH HEH
HEH HEH HEH
I am doing nothing, except what you asked
gimme that, son of a bitch
GIMME DAAT
"A SLOW and EVEN PACE is recommended"
GIMME DAT WAAHH
OH FUCK WHAT?
"A slow and even pace is recommended"
Be careful not to tou-
Fuck fuck fuck. Ah
shoot
tOOtoiES
FrOOtieS
Okay
Oh great. Yeah, that's great
Okay, is that blood or is that wires? Is that blood or wires Oh God. My hand doesn't go that far
My hand doesn't go that far
My hand just doesn't go that far apparently
Come on. Oohhh
Return the same music box? The same one?
wha- WHAAAHAH
AAAHH
AAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH (someone help mark!)
hey a coin
HAH
Is it now? Is this slow and even pace?
recommend-
AAHHHHHH
FUUCKING COOOCK
Fuck you. Fuck you game. Ok. Fuck you. Fuck you. That's bullshit. That's bullshit
Okay
You mean boop his snoot?
*boop!
HUEEEEEGHGHGHHHH
*giggles
ohhh god you fiNIckY biiitch
Give him to me and I move on
Okay repair Foxy. Lezz doo dizz
hooly shit
HOHH
OHH
OH
OHHHH
Why would I do that? I don't want to do that
I don't wanna do any of that. Why would I do it literally anything that you have for me and tell me to do hey, there we go
I didn't know there would be a coin here somewhere
Okay, all right
Oh
I don't like that drawer. That drawer is no fun.
Oh hello
I'm do? Okay.
Head? How bout'
You know what actually, I'm not gonna mess with anything (oh rlly)
Let's just pop you back
WHOA WHOA WHOA
WHOA
WH- WHOA
I'm sorry, excuse me?
Okay
*thumpy leggies tumpin' around
Okay, that's not good
I- I am!
Oh no what?
oh
How?
Do I do that? Oh my god
Huh? Whoo!
Okay, I'm watching you
Yeah, okay, okay
WHOAAAA
Okay?
Okay? Alright
This one? Okay
This your chest one? The interior one? I know that
Okay you son of a bitch, you're not so bad. You're not so bad.
Oh
Why do you have so many fuses? It doesn't make any sense. It doesn't make any sense at all, okay
Blue
Okay this one?
yea yea yea
Alright. Uh, this way up
Okay
HEEEYYYYAYAYAYAY
*chomp chomp chomp chomp
HOOOOO
Okay
I'm guessing it's the same color
Okay, here we go
Okay, let me just see when
OH HEHEHEHEH
OH
Great that's wonderful
That simple, huh?
Did we want Pirate Cove reopen?
Oh god
Oh. Oh my god, that is horrible
ohhheueghghhgh
ohhheheheheh
HAH HAH HAH HAH
*tries to eat Circus Baby but fails to do so
Oh I can't eat you
HUEUEEGHGHGHH
Let's just do better
You could't gimme something
Mark, in Baby's voice: Ah NeVAhh GonnAH GivE Yah
Ahhnything-
M: Oh yeah?
Not with that attitude you're not!
B: JuSt Trahh, Ahh'll kelL Yah Deahd
OH I'll kill you dead first
Alright Babehh
Maybe not Baby. Maybe not Baby. Baby maybe not
Right.
WHOOOLLYYYY
Alright, whatever you say. I'm gonna go listen and make sure for myself. I like making an informed decision about my life
So I'm gonna listen to this weird tape that I found randomly in the middle of
Did he?
(look to your right mark)
WHOA WHAT THE FUCK? YOU, NOT HERE.
NOOOOOOO
Yeah, Jeremy would need to be replaced soon
WHO. THE HELL. DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?
Is my question to you
Do you know who I am? Do you see this crown on my head?
Do you know what I will do to you if you even come a little bit close to me. I RIPPED Freddy apart
I ripped his chest off of his chest and I will do the same to your cake and your ballsack and your ears (that's probably a bit too harsh over there mark)
I'll replace it all. You'll look stupid as hell. Don't try me. I will murder you. Okay? All right
I'm gonna leave now before I have to make good on my promises and you know, how much I-
keep a promise
I don't like you
I'm a say it right now. I don't like you
Whatever you are
May I suggest that you rename yourself to
Senior Bag of Dick?
That's all the time I got
There's only two sections left
Vent repair, which I don't think is gonna- and night terrors, which is great. And then there's the nightmare world of stuff
But let's just go for that for now and see where we are before. We try any twenty mode of this bullshit here
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought in the comments below check out the other Five nights at Freddy's stuff
I have all over my channel literally everywhere
and just
AHH
MAH KNEE
Thanks for watching. Oh, sorry
Thanks for watching. All this stuff will be in the description. Leave a like. Subscribe if you want more
That's always nice ring that bell cuz that's pretty cool. And just thanks for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video BUH BYE!